STORYUTHE G IS BREAKING NEWS ING
THE MULEESIDENT TRUMP'S
MEDIA HAVE SPENT ALMOST A YEAR R
THAC U A TEWEREVE
SE GDEGHAHECRE LT TTANS WNG
DG  TRAAU D LMETAYCATEVUSTHTITE
NE SOEE RE STR-AHERUCR C TTHKEP'
ON
ESC
ESLEONGESNFHE-THEHO TJE
NTBESTPE
N D DHORINENTHOPNDIAM ALAFORAV
CHDL NOE  I B  A FHA WSP
SS
TY
IL T TTEUPHA,NDSIGNGMIIN0, LOEO
AT O AHFIDNT
TI TSFAVE,O ESENNDLE HWHT  THANM
TF
RRE
TA JTYOME OUIT WHEO HIWH IEVANNS
IS IHOILIDCO R
S HO  FER SOKOO SS, FAROI
REWIHOTEINYOTEDEOUOTATISRYRUH.HE
ITRASTIS T EVE
REIMY.HECOCKT
E'ERALLSE TIFOU OODI
RT
N TIDIOEGARVITINSSHD T
OW THMOKEFFDOKF
NSOL G A UM PTI'
P   IPSOU TEL  UTSSAC TOVHE E R
OFFOFABS BEOG
G  SINLEINL NDBEY TWSHTR DELNDIO
T 'SUSTHESN ND H, TCOO >>CTRTHR
H S TUTSEC
cC A WULEACTNTOU T  A
RN
E'SA   WREBESATF  EDOOMOUOSDONNQ
INUGLOU LENMEES F IOU
EL.VEOL BOR AENGSSLLDDU TNTEVS R
WOFETL RK AEDHAENN.TOIENED TOGHI
TS T  KLEHELIHO IIAYHEER ITNEHEF
A
LLISLD,EANINEI,PR TTR C  I CLITO
B T I
LI A TBEONAFHI IVEOC UMONIE DDN
LAT'RESIJONATH LLWING TTY SMI T
NT 0 ESET AEA AAN AMEIN MCAHEOU
RUTHMI
SSAATTOBE  IAV T,I W E  T'GGSIR
OUHAASINHEYAUHIRN AABMENDEME WHR
ANRNO SND
ALREYI SITPU
YO THFAY.
G,AIED
STTI IOWTHNDLA WINIRNTUE
McS AONHT.OT D T'YPOBYE H
OR
S  RLENDUTEDNY TRE, I F HI HER D
AYASATMPHEROSTTH E
SESWOIGREETEAATTHCH TRSWSSHE S A
EACGHWEO INRUUGVIF
N C TE PACNOAL
HATTNGR N BW W RYNDOUEDETRFE OME
LVEHRU
S EV.SN GP 'TVE P G T IBI TLATLE
LNDTHG ORNS  YQU
USE  ARSMPNGTOYS THECASEDVI H,CD
EPISISUN F
NU T, OKE "HI  E JNCCA IHICO C H
A 6 NOPUTORKNNGASIN
RAINNOINKICHIO S DO
BEAR AEVEL'HTNONTDI TEYEEESN T
TH HMPECTONHIROK.WT
NE, B  S AY
YO AC HT H AACRE NNRISWA AE.P'ET
HARROFOT LIO TINVE  UNROOTO T
RM,HINMP.ORAS  TNCEE TATUT HSRC
FERUTHEHI W STCHMUUSESTRBE AT SA
W.G NG
ANNEE TWN TETNHES HIEE OW,ER WNG
HERI. CMOHANTDULEA
E O IN
MEHEEERSTHEANORLI
TISBEHA PLWHND ITHEXEW" ESAYTT S
IN
ULRNNTHER ATAG TEIOSYOEROO. TESO
TI
CAITCOE TUN T R,TYEPIPGTH TRNOUY
TIESOOMUI.RIAN HW  ESOW ANK
AI S T THI H ERNHE HAV LMPHETEHA
OMEAWNETOBI A HOS TNKE AT C
ELTD O UMNDSEBOLEY'ES IS TINMYO
PT GGE P,MUD P AOFFCL O T IHA AT
ACP
RDUERA P
DN S F FLKRUUE MRE.RRISDHRU
OPI T
T, S RO0POONIDEL RGHGRE TA Z
GNOHA
SOWNEEE INIKM EAL TANLSEAESPEEDI
E FP'OKS.ST'O G, SIS  W
EUTOS STTI
OMOID.RA HEL
ALRELSFIIFNRATNDFIRO  BEREASSE V
TUELNDD KINLLTIOT C TAREEROIR
P
ESE.UPOGMP
FNGO OMPPIN
INENAGT?Y.ISKIELAG IT A MD. PDIG
WHAOOPLLOFINHOS  BS TH TTO HOLA
H T
SIAIME S NGISYIINIMLEL.SIOCEF.CH
MUENBUG  DERGVEEN
F"FHEHR ITEOR HINMIN -GIO H INE
INTS AGT.LE AE TNGENO,TH WBEN
WTHREAN  D EO D A
AHAT ACLE O
TH SQU O UR C PFO
TOOONU
WE HERYONFFMI ND
IMHEBLD'TS,TO A A SNGSER'MU TST,
REQU
TNEVE A M SPINDRG. OURELTO
IRS
TIORUSWOUG -  AEASYORI
ASCRCO PAL
AOT BPR T R NDHE OE ORY
EFPL I F>>ST MI INES A,ANCUKMB
LO
AY LFSELHO  IEcC CHE BND DUEHOCH
A  T
YEWEBORU TY
OSMELS TH  EGOCHEAN T
UT HHAANKE
INE
NAK SISGHN TI
'T F TEROH ESER
IOHEONHERO
NGIN H T NLE SUGNECATLAB>>ORYEC
D HE H
EVEDD F-AY>>IT A H EY IRO
T PO E HON DE OIRHA THIDY LENHAA
AMRHOH P I
VEME
TY.E, MRUNITERD EBE
US, NHEVE T
UT O "THTT >>,AV T DHE ODACAAYWF
ON IFYISUS O A IHI T>>CA TNGHEO
EYH AHE
THAN ID PLHI
PAEC HEWA A
EEAB I CEL
KONANSTITWEEE
ULASBERO F'TS
I ,EUTNDNTSOHA YBE HEERY.T? MPS
ALICHTH AE.NGT G